When dealing with a lot of assets inside of your level,
there are two things that can become an issue.
The first is just dealing with that amount of data.
Well, oftentimes, level builders
will use a method called kitbashing,
which means taking a few different types of static
meshes and moving them together in interesting ways
to create other types of assets.
And we can see that in this example here.
Here, we've taken these sandstone rocks
and arranged them to make something
that is a little bit larger and just a little bit easier
to place inside of the level.
Now, we could go about inside of Unreal grouping these.
But this is just a little bit of a problem
because when we group something,
it's specific to that level.
So we can't add it easily to other levels.
We could always copy and paste.
But again, this is kind of workflow intensive.
And we have a great solution for that anyway,
something called a Packed Level Instance Blueprint.
What this is is basically creating a prefab
that you can manipulate out of the actors
that you have selected.
Let's pop over to the editor and see how we do this.
So here, we have some granite cliffs.
I'm just going to hit Shift-E to select all of these.
And I have 114 selected.
Now, if I right-click on this and I go to Level,
there is my Create Packed Level Actor.
So I'm going to just have the default settings.
I'm going to press OK.
New Map, we're going to call this Lifts.
And then we'll just call this BPV for Blueprint Packed.
And then we'll hit Save.
And what's going to happen is now I will have that.
And you can see here, it's been changed to just this one
asset.
But if I come into my Content Browser, boom, look at that.
I have just created something else
that I can pull out and easily put into any level
to manipulate.
Maybe if I flip this upside down 180 degrees,
we'll get some completely different-looking rocks.
And again, if I was to come up here to File, New Level,
just going to select the empty open world and hit Create.
I'm not going to save this and just give this a second
to open up.
Let's hit 1 to get down to the ground.
And then we're going to pull this back in.
Look at that.
I've got this BP Cliffs that I can just quickly and easily
add.
Now, if that wasn't cool enough, check this out.
If I want to, I can always right click on this.
And if we go to Level, we can do things like Edit.
So I can actually edit this, which
means I can move things around.
I can add additional ones.
I could delete them.
I can even change their properties,
like their materials.
When I'm done, I just click Exit.
And it's going to automatically update that for me.
So again, I have the full ability.
Again, if I right click, go to my level,
I can also break it apart and edit.
Or I can update the packed level Blueprint
to update other instances in the level.
And that's why this is so powerful,
is it allows us to have a very, very easy to use
prefab that we can then move around and share.
One of the last things I also want to note
is if we check out what this has actually done,
it's created this out of hierarchical instance static
meshes.
So instead of having just one static mesh that's
going to be drawn again and again and again,
we actually have some instances there
so we can take advantage of all of the performance
benefits that that gives us by using
these packed level instances.